justin and hailey bieber released
episode two of their new facebook
watch show bieber's on watch and this
time around justin and haley cook pasta
and they also discussed justin's
depression
yeah so justin admits he was on an
antidepressant which is no longer
and haley has been helping him with his
acne during uh quarantine which he said
is helping his mental state as well
what's up everyone it's haley and justin
and as you guys know we are in
quarantine so we wanted to bring you
guys into some of the things that we've
been doing and
um in this video you'll see that we are
cooking some
pasta together yeah we made one of our
uh a recipe that we actually both really
enjoy so
hope you guys enjoy it and follow along
i love pasta
a lot of people struggle with depression
and and people
look at it like it's a weakness but
until you have it you know it's
you you know you started being more
consistent with talking to someone with
a therapist
and i think you've learned a big lesson
of um
you like like like having help isn't
doesn't mean you're weak it just means
like
you know you care about yourself and you
care about those around you and you want
to be a healthy individual
and also you got to be the healthiest
version of yourself
too and you got to strive to want to be
that especially in a partnership and in
a relationship
because when you're in a relationship
that person isn't it's not up to them to
save you it's not their job to fix you
um you got to want to do that on your
own and you got to want to constantly be
becoming the best version of yourself so
the two of you can
i gotta say when you tell me that you're
proud of me
it means more than anybody else
nelson says don't need to see this in
this way
i mean one thing yes you can talk about
the idea that they're doing this show
kind of into their lives and the
quarantine a lot of people are starting
to
do this like even cooking shows like amy
schumer's doing a cooking show
and not to bring up her name but selena
gomez is about to do a cooking show from
quarantine
as well for hbo max so i'm not i'm not
comparing here this just happens to
happenstance
that she's doing one as well but no but
this isn't their permanent thing that
i'm doing i guess just with this episode
they want to do a cooking thing so yeah
i don't know how long you can keep this
up but it is
here hearing i'm talking about the
depression stuff is interesting because
it still
blows my mind of how severe it was i
mean we knew justin really went through
a dark time but
just hearing him talk about you you
really understand how dark it was
yeah and i don't know if they fully even
still have it figured out because i
think it takes a really long time to
you know get through that it still sort
of
sounds like what they're saying are
things that they've learned as opposed
to
things that they're sort of reflecting
on like it really very much
sounds like this is still a struggle in
a lot of ways
for them but i i mean aside from the
production value and that i wish that
they had better lighting and microphones
so i could actually hear what they were
saying
you know i i think that this is the this
is just an extension
of you know social media for them and i
think that this is a little bit of a
better sort of more comfortable way that
isn't
you know instagram and maybe opens them
up to a little bit of a different
audience where
you know they don't have to deal with
the same sort of
i don't know comments or sort of quick
little bites it sounds like they're just
trying to slow things down a little bit
and you know maybe be a little bit more
sort of open
and less um of the manufactured
perfection that you tend to get on
instagram that's sort of the platform
for that
but i do i do like this i do like them
deciding to do this together
and out of all the things that they
could have chose to talk about i'm glad
that they talked about this because
if you have the choice to sort of waste
your time and your audience
with sort of frivolous nonsense or
actually have a conversation about
something meaningful that someone you
might get out of i'm happy they're
choosing that
you know it's it's great right uh peter
says beautiful
seeing the couple amazing cooking uh
question says i'm glad justin and haley
are open and honest with all of us to
share i believe when you have anxiety
or depression i just find it helps me
talk to someone or just talk about it
uh jesse says it's nice to see
celebrities uh talking so openly
and honest i was also impressed with um
how
uh informed haley was on the subject too
it really seems like she
you know she understands she's not just
talking felicity about it she really
understands what justin was going
through and
how he had to deal with it and he
mentions too um
you know he mentions you know i can't
wait to get out on tour which i don't
remember when his tour was supposed to
start i think it was made that it was
supposed to start so that's like
a huge void that's not in his life so
like you're saying like doing this is
kind of a way to fill that
void a little tiny bit obviously he's
not singing in front of a crowd but at
least
it is a way to still have that
connection with your fans
yeah and i also like where they're doing
it you know i like that they
didn't stay in la and they realized that
it would just be better for
you know both of them and just service
to go to their place uh just outside of
toronto which is which is awesome i love
it